- Congratulations.
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
- [Kelly] You have a baby boy, right?
- Baby boy, yes.
- [Kelly] Was it exciting?
(audience applauds)
That's exciting.
I, I was excited when I found out,
because I had a little girl, just like you
and then, I had a little boy.
And I was, I was excited,
because I got one of both.
Were you?
- I'm, one of both.
- Yeah.
- And I, I think I'm good.
- You're done?
- Shop is closed.
Yes, one of each.
It's exciting, it
definitely was, you know,
just a different way, I did surrogacy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And...
- [Kelly] That was the second time, right?
- The second time, yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The first time I carried on my own.
The second time I did surrogacy
and it's, I mean, it's amazing.
- I wish I had known about that,
I had horrible pregnancies.
I was like, hospitalized and so...
- Oh, my gosh.
- Yeah, so, I, but I didn't
really even know about it
or know what it was, like in
my circle, but it's brilliant.
- It's, it's amazing.
I had reasons why I
couldn't carry my second.
- No, me too.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And it's, it's such a
blessing that we have this
and I, my sister, Kim
had two babies through surrogacy.
She had two that she carried on her own
and her last two were through surrogacy.
If it wasn't for Kimberly,
I definitely don't think I
would've been as comfortable.
- You wouldn't have been aware.
- [Khloe] I wouldn't have been aware,
I wouldn't have known as much.
I watched her go through her journey
and I'm so grateful for
how open she's always been
about her journey, because,
and not every journey's the same.
Mine was very different from hers.
- Yeah.
- I think her journey was way more,
just, I think she was
more maybe not involved,
I don't know the term,
but like, it was just
more comfortable for her.
For me, I'm such a control freak.
- Oh yeah, you'd be like,
"What are they eating?
What are they doing?
What are they putting in their body?"
- [Khloe] You're a stranger,
I just have to trust you.
And I love my surrogate, she was amazing,
but I'm still like,
"I need you sitting
next to me all the time.
I need to know what you're doing.
What are you eating?"
- Yeah.
- So, it was...
- I think I would've been
a little like that too,
had I known, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And a control freak
I take as a compliment.
So, I'm not offended
that I'm a control freak.
- I don't know if it's like,
a control, it's because people
always say control freak,
but it's like, or you just
know what you want and like.
- You're very particular.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I think that
that's fine, it's, it's...
- It's not fine for other people.
- It cuts through the BS.
- It's great for me.
- You know, yeah, I think
they just need to get over it.
So wait, so you, you haven't
revealed your son's name yet.
So, is there a, is it like
a family name, like a hint?
Like...
- Well...
- [Kelly] Is it like...
- My daughter says his
name is Snowy and...
- [Kelly] Oh, your daughter.
(Kelly chuckles)
- It's not snowy, so that's the hint.
(Khloe laughs)
- I was like, "Were you a
big Game of Thrones fan?"
- Oh, my gosh.
- Jon Snow.
(Kelly laughs)
- I swear she just,
does things to sort of mess with me,
but his name is not Snowy.